you can play elden ring early on xbox
we've got details on elden rings day one
patch and more
from software's hugely anticipated rpg
elden ring launches tomorrow but you may
not need to wait until then to start
playing especially if you have an xbox
and are willing to potentially been some
roles however there is a catch it is
already february 25th in some parts of
the world so changing your xbox region
to say new zealand or australia will
allow you to start playing elden ring
right now this also requires a digital
copy of the game to change your region
on xbox you'll need to navigate to the
language and location section of the
settings menu then select language
region to choose a different place it
bears mentioning that this is not an
officially sanctioned xbox feature
though it has been demonstrated to work
with previous games people have reported
that doing this could lead to action
being taken against their accounts
though your mileage may vary so if
you're willing to risk a ban to play a
little earlier you can elden ring
officially launches at midnight local
time on february 25th except on pc where
it arrives at 3 pm pt 6 pm et today
february 24th if you haven't already
pre-loading is now available on all
platforms which should help you jump
right into the game as soon as possible
upon release officially or otherwise
and before you start up elden ring for
the first time you'll need to download a
day one patch the patch promises some
fixes to various bugs and slight tweaks
to elements like player controls and
game balance the patch notes don't give
a great amount of detail regarding what
exactly is meant by points like improved
player controls some of the other
details are self-explanatory like one
that fixes frame rate drops and another
that addresses a bug impacting xbox
wireless headsets the notes also
mentioned that ray tracing is still
planned for a future announcement but
didn't give further timing some of the
other fixes mentioned were various text
and balance adjustments in pc event
fixes and more we've got the full list
for the day one patch on gamespot.com
following the usual leak microsoft has
now officially announced the games with
gold lineup for march 2022 next month's
reported games with gold lineup includes
the post-societal adventure game the
flame in the flood the action-based
soccer game street power soccer and the
rpg sacred two fallen angel spongebob's
truth or square which has players using
plankton's memory machine to find the
formula to the krabby patty's secret
formula is also included in march with
games with gold it's still february so
don't forget to grab the remaining games
with gold titles for this month
including broken sword 5 aerial knights
never yield and band of bugs and xbox
game pass subscribers have more games to
grab this month too some of the new
additions to the catalog this month
include dragon ball fighters galactic
civilizations 3 super mega baseball 3
and alice madness returns
are you willing to risk a ban to play
elden ring early let me know why or why
not in the comments and as always leave
a like subscribe and tune in tomorrow
for another episode of gamespot news
[Music]
you